we are told that teresa consumes both
bagels and toy cars and they tell us
that the table above shows teresa's
marginal utility from bagels and toy
cars and the first question is what is
her total utility from purchasing three
toy cars so pause this video and see if
you can answer that
all right now let's work through this
together so let's just make sure we
understand this table here so this says
that the first bagel that teresa
consumes she gets eight units of
marginal utility from that then the
second bagel she gets a little bit less
marginal utility she some of her big
bagel craving has already been satisfied
by that first one and then the third
bagel the marginal utility goes down a
little bit and then that keeps happening
for each incremental bagel and on the
toy side we see that that first toy she
gets a lot of marginal utility 10 and
then the next toy gets a little bit less
and then you see that the marginal
utility for each incremental toy gets a
little bit lower and lower
so now let's answer the first question
what is her total utility from
purchasing three toy cars
well that first toy car she gets utility
of 10
then that second toy car she gets a
utility of eight
and then that third toy car her marginal
utility for that incremental car
is six
so the total utility is going to be ten
plus 8 plus 6 which is what 10 plus 14
this is going to be equal to 24 units of
marginal utility
all right now let's do part two
teresa's weekly income is 11
the price of a bagel is two dollars and
the price of a toy car is one dollar
what quantity of bagels and toy cars
will maximize teresa's utility if she
spends her entire weekly income on
bagels and toy cars
explain your answer using marginal
analysis so once again pause this video
and see if you can figure that out
all right now let's do this together and
i'll scroll down a little bit so i have
some space
so the key thing is is when once we know
the price of a bagel and the price of a
toy and we know the marginal utility for
every incremental bagel or toy we can
figure out our bang for our buck we can
figure out what is going to be the
marginal utility per dollar from that
incremental bagel and that incremental
toy car
and so
we can let's just explain first so
teresa
teresa
will
maximize
maximize
her
marginal utility per
incremental dollar per
dollar or let me put it this way per
dollar
when
making
purchases on the margin
making maybe income making purchases
on
the
margin
so her next incremental purchase
her next
incremental
incremental
purchase
so we can write over here
bagel
marginal utility per dollar that'll be
one row here and then we could write car
or toy
marginal utility
per dollar
and then let me set up these rows right
over here
and then we could think about it if she
for the first one
for the second one
for the third one
for the fourth one
let's see if we go up to six fifth one
and then we go to our sixth one
so let's start with bagels
bagels cost two dollars so that first
bagel is she gets eight marginal utility
units well that's going to be four
marginal utility units per dollar eight
divided by two so that's four
units per dollar and then that second
bagel she gets seven units but it costs
two dollars so it's seven divided by two
units per dollar so that's going to be
3.5
and then 6 divided by 2 is 3. 5 divided
by 2 is
2.5
4 divided by 2
is
2.
so that fifth bagel two marginal utility
units per dollar and then that sixth
bagel three divided by two is 1.5
marginal utility units per dollar and
now we can think about toys
each toy is one dollar so she gets 10
marginal utility units from that first
toy it only costs her a dollar so it's
10 utility units per dollar so it's 10
there
it would be 8 here we're just dividing
each of these by 1. so 6 here so it's
going to be the same number again
4
3 and two
so now that we set this up and let me
scroll down a little bit so i have a
little bit more space i have all the
data i need
we can think about what would be
rational for for thinking about how
she's going to spend that eleven dollars
per week
her first purchase she's like wow
from the get-go that if i'm picking
between bagels and toys that first toy
has a much higher marginal utility per
dollar than that first bagel so she's
going to start here
and then she says okay next do i want to
buy a bagel or a toy but even that
second toy the marginal utility per
dollar is still higher than that first
bagel so then she'll buy a second toy
then she'll think about it and so far
she's only spent two dollars so we have
a lot of money still left
then she'll think about okay do i want
to spend that next incremental amount on
a toy or bagel well still you get she
gets more marginal utility per dollar
from the toy so she'll spend that she's
spent three dollars so far one dollar
two dollars three dollars and now when
she thinks about how to spend her next
few dollars she said well now i'm
indifferent between bagels and toys the
marginal utility per dollar is the same
so she might maybe spend the next one on
a toy
and then right after that she'll go to
bagels finally and buy a bagel
well let's think about how much she has
spent so far she spent four dollars on
toys and two dollars on bagels
so the order might look something
like this
and then she goes and maybe
buys her bagel
and now the marginal utility per dollar
for that incremental bagel is higher
than for her next toy and so then she'll
probably buy she would buy another bagel
right here let's see how much money she
has spent two bagels are four dollars
plus she spent four dollars on toys
because their dollar each was eight
dollars so she still has three dollars
to spend now her marginal utility per
dollar is neutral between bagels and
toys between the incremental that third
bagel and that's fifth toy so she's
indifferent between the two so she could
probably get both of them so she might
do something like that by that
and then
she could buy that or she could do that
in the other order let's see how much
money she spent she has spent five
dollars on toys
and
she has spent six dollars on bagels and
so she has spent her eleven dollars and
so to answer the first question so she
would
buy
she would buy
five toys
five toys
and
three bagels
and three
bagels
based
on
this strategy
of maximizing
marginal utility per dollar
for each
incremental
incremental
purchase
did i answer all the questions we so we
said the quantity of bagels and toys
that will maximize her marginal utility
if she spends her weekly income and then
we have explained using marginal
analysis yup we're looking good